Now, I'm going to ask you a question. Given this
very simple, implementation of the barrier decrementing count and count
becoming zero resetting it to N by the last
processor and all the other guys waiting on the count
not being not yet being zero, do you see
any problem with this algorithm? And this is an open-ended
question. So I want you to think about it
and see, could this lead to any raise condition. And,
and I mentioned to you when we talked about
mutual exclusion algorithm itself that raise conditions are the bane
of parallel programming. So, when
you're implementing synchronization algorithms you
better be absolutely certain that there are no raise conditions.